[Music]
inés hot sex are known for their
incisive lyrics that capture the mood in
Germany and playing unusual instruments
for hip-hop they kicked off their US
tour at the Kennedy Center and
Washington DC
[Music]
but then they moved on to play at
colleges and schools the ban whose name
translates as 1 ^ 6
went down well at the Kennedy Center one
of the for instruments unusual long
story so you don't hear in hip-hop very
often but the band are not only in the
u.s. to play concerts they're there to
help teach German in cooperation with DW
I think music can transport feelings and
it's a lot of fun it's much easier to
learn a language while having fun and
far less complicated than in an ordinary
classroom
Zacks have already been to 16 countries
with VW's video diary project Indonesia
for example game called charades you
have to mine
[Music]
the band and e-w have produced 40
episodes of the diary to date teachers
and students all over the world can
download the videos to teach and learn
German in a fun way
[Music]
I showed quite a football
[Music]
to prove
[Music]
it's proved a popular concept the videos
have been viewed and downloaded hundreds
of thousands of times mark and I said
last month it's like when children sing
along to a song even if they don't know
the language the rhythm and the beat
getting you involved this is the trick
we use so students of German can access
the language better the band members are
very excited to be in the u.s. got
familiar hip hop hip hop artists it's a
dream to play in the US where it all
began and stunts the funky their tour
comprises 14 workshops and 18 concerts
in total Heinz hogs X taking America by
storm with German rap